[Music]
he might be cheating actually
watch this [ __ ] man he does like these
quick looks that's so weird bro like why
are you doing that
if there's a head shot from rob's here
on the player on cat oh god
now it's suddenly very very doable one
shot and he goes to go down
oh no he's done it he's absolutely done
it
i could just go back in time and you
know tell my dad that
i could earn so much money playing cs so
they pull this young kid in
no one's ever heard of him and he comes
in and he starts buying up to that level
spreader that's massive shoes to fill
you know you've got nico's shoes to fill
there is a smoke there but chris j
looking out towards mid
here comes the hit yeah that's what man
actually helped him with the robs and a
great cordless phrase in
and he gets oh headshots in a row
unbelievable and that's gonna be over
time look at oscar just laughing
before we get into the video i want to
just remind everyone that if you like
what we do here at the score esports
please subscribe to the channel it helps
a lot anyway
romps isn't like most cs players you
used to seeing your favorite pro rage
this [ __ ] ross is always chill
overall i'm really calm i only focus on
the game like i never
rage i don't think i've never even
raised the stream have you heard stories
of pros dropping out of school to pursue
their dream
well robs waited until a team could work
around his school schedule before he
signed a contract
he is still going in school even now
when we're playing at the big
tournaments because his school is like
really willing to
let him live this dream and he didn't
even have to work through crappy teams
to get his shot at the big leagues robs
went straight from
fpl playing online to mousesports he
skipped
going through some semi-professional
teams and it's like totally different to
how
it used to happen usually people would
play events they would play online
tournaments they would prove themselves
in
lesser teams and then get picked up by a
bigger team it was very fast
i was just like a small kid playing from
my home and
i was playing some online leagues and
suddenly i was
getting to play against the pros but
before romps was playing in major
tournaments
he was a star on fpl a lot of the people
in estonia
trying to face it and i got into the
basic rounds
there was a lot of money on the line it
was really competitive since you were
already playing for something
but the thing is robs was so good on fpl
that
people actually thought he was cheating
they wanted to know if i was uh
it was really that talented and they
started calling me a cheater at one
point
can you stop playing like [ __ ] drops
please we need your cheats man
i don't know why the [ __ ] we don't just
ban him it's never gonna show up at the
level i don't even want to join a team
pros who get caught cheating are
universally despised but no one gets
accused more than a young
unproven players playing online no one
can verify whether you're cheating or
not
so a guy like ross playing an fpl was a
prime cheating suspect
and no romps wasn't cheating but the
accusations had him shook
the people who i looked up to started
calling me a cheater then
they wasn't good i i didn't really want
to play at that point
because it's not good when you look up
to a person and then
suddenly he starts calling you cheater
man eventually rops got so good
and the accusations got so bad that face
it who
run fpl flew him out to their london
headquarters to play under supervised
conditions to prove he wasn't cheating
i think that we were already considering
him getting him in mouse first when i
was in a
mouse liner back then i saw him playing
an fpl and he was really playing good
like at some point people were thinking
that he was cheating
he was really good i think he's really
talented and he's he's proving it so
i think that he has a lot to go still it
was a kind of like a
zero to 100 story real fast and
well it turned out good and obviously i
wasn't cheating so
i've made it here now being accused of
hacking in-game was
hardly the biggest obstacle rops had to
overcome though
it was a normal day i went to school i
ended
some late night cs and then in the
evening
my mom came to my room and i was like
okay don't bother me i'm playing
i'm busy now and i'm just having some
fun but
she said it's serious and she just sat
me down to
have a talk and
she let me know that um my dad commit
suicide
if i could just go back in time and you
know tell my dad that
i could earn so much money playing cs
and
i just wait like things will work out
robs had dealt with some deep personal
loss but
from the outside looking in he was the
kid who made it
a lot of people saw him as something of
an inspiration
but the obstacles kept coming see
rob's name was cleared and he finally
made it onto a pro team
but he had some pretty big shoes to fill
this is characteristic of nico not only
picking up the deal in the pistol round
so he's still finding a shot or two
three
that's the difference and now they know
that the man is behind yellow as well
twist will fight back but nico's still
alive he's still kicking and he finds
another one
four headshots for nico and the pistol
absolutely unreal nico was an insane
player but people thought he was
carrying him out and when robs joined up
they weren't sure if he could do the
same
so they pull this young kid in no one's
ever heard of him well
the hardcore have heard of him but not
many in the wider scene i've heard of
this kid
and he comes in and he starts playing up
to that level straight up that's massive
shoes to fill
you know you've got nico's shoes to fill
and this kid comes in
really calm about how he goes about
things he has no bones about the fact
that he's there to replace nico he's
he's there to become the new rops he
doesn't care about nico or simple
or anyone else he's there to make a name
for himself what they didn't realize is
that mauser's strategy was different
no one can say that if nico was in this
team they would probably be better right
but it's not revolving around
one single player anymore it's more
about team making good decisions
and playing well as a unit instead goes
jr now it's kashanda whoa
what the hell is that he's aware of this
he's got the angle are they cleared
right head shot a second one
all right it's domination in ramp room
try and hold off the rotations oscar's
gone chris isn't up still in the picture
oh i'm still very much in the round oh
chris he's found three it's down to it
two one two
chris can he close this with an ace oh
my god
chris the wolf of wall street gets an
ace
and it's championship point mouse sports
but they were still lacking that
special something that takes a team to
the top and as it turned out
that something was a new igl kerrigan
is the best game leader available some
of the best in gamers in history
the potential for this to be a
championship team with him is big
they've never had in-game leader like
him this could be a clutch oh
like in the making right now from x7
he's picked up the awp mccarran
he's got the off angle he's nailed it
and that's it
mousesports they came back against tyloo
and they've won against ends i cannot
believe that they've done this
what a beautiful run from mount sports
kerrigan believed in him
he knew that robs wasn't all hype and he
believed that with just a little bit of
support
props could shine basically we are doing
everything to set up robs um
not meaning that everybody else doesn't
have the role within the team but i feel
like if we can turn robs into a sipnix
kind of player
you have very very unique player in your
team and you can always rely on
unravel to turn up if there's a headshot
from robs here
on the player on cat oh god now it's
suddenly
very very doable one shot anywhere on
the body for crims to go down
oh no rops he's done it he's absolutely
done it
so i've never had a dedicated in-game
leader he really knows how to work this
team and
put everyone into place so that is the
biggest difference
and the new mouseport begin to crush
their competition
is he really going to take this fight
against creek versus zorp and precise as
always
an 11 for walks it get a crucial opener
for mouse sports
it was six
[Music]
and walk sick is a beast in the side
it's rob's here hiding 3k
for him making it a fourth as well why
not the ace
harrigan an unknown entity an unknown
factor flicks on down
drops seven seconds
[Music]
everyone on mouse now had a role to play
kerrigan decided that robs would do best
as a lurker and as it turns out
he was right oh the backstab though he's
coming in
this could be it boys that's one
oh my god
was named the 10th best cs go player in
the world on hltv's 2019 ranking
up nine spots from the year before but
robs is still going
his 2019 ended with great placements at
big tournaments
and maos is a strong contender heading
into the next major
despite every obstacle every challenge
robs finally made it
he went from an online up-and-comer to
one of cs go's greatest players
his talent and determination in the face
of adversity cannot
be denied thanks for watching if you
want more content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages